there are a lot of things in blood-borne
that I never really got to talk about
these are discoveries that shocked or
impressed me in some way when I learned
about them so when I tell you about them
today I'm kind of betting that you guys
will give the same response let's get
started
the first is something that blew
people's minds about five months ago
user Chim Cheree of reddit didn't run
past the Winterland an enemy like a sane
person would instead she actually took
the time to look closely at it and
studied what she found was pretty
chilling she discovered that the winter
lanterns bear striking resemblance to
the plain doll from our dream down to
the smallest little detail on their
clothing every fold of the cloth even
when you read over that thread now he
realized that most people didn't believe
her at first until a guy named Jeremy
took high-res screenshots of the enemy
let's take a close look at what they
found the red scarf overlays perfectly
with this piece of flesh the four seams
on the torso are visible under lanten's
clothing the corset even takes the same
angle on both waists and there's even
the rumpled v-shaped edge that runs
around the entire body the only thing
that doesn't appear is the dolls Shore
but even that could be represented by
the tendrils coming down from the brain
so what are the consequences of this
what is the relationship between the
doll and the winter lanterns with the
knowledge we have I feel like there's
only two explanations my short answer
for this video is that the doll in
menses is nightmare must appear there as
a figment of our own consciousness or
perhaps the doll imagery was brought
into the nightmare by Mikkel ash when
the dream was conceived there's a lot I
want to say on this but it's too
detailed for this video so I'll write a
document and I'll leave a link to it in
the description if you're interested
moving on but still speaking of the doll
did you know that she has eyes on the
inside of her head most of you probably
learned this trick from epic named bro
who did it in his first episode of his
blood-borne let's play I believe having
eyes on the inside is synonymous with
gaining insight as mentioned by the
third of the umbilical cord description
and it makes you wonder do you think her
eyes here
a part of the badly mapped texture are
they hidden easter egg or are they
something more surely there's more to
the doll than there seems at first
glance she even has a unique piece of
dialogue that you can easily go the
whole game without hearing the
requirements for this dialogue appearing
are pretty unclear but it should
eventually happen to you have a listen
Oh flora of the Moon of the dream Oh
little ones o fleeting will of the
Ancients let the hunter be safe let him
find comfort and let this dream his
captor foretell a pleasant awakening the
doll wants you to be safe she wants you
to awaken and to forget basically she
wants you to go through with the accept
death ending where you kneel before
Germann the ending that other hunters
like Jura and Eileen surely got hunters
who experienced the dream likely served
a purpose on a different night of the
hunt and then were removed when gurmann
grants you mercy you become one of the
many gravestones marking the other
hunters who passed through here as you
did in new game+ you will sometimes
spawn in to see the doll behind you
kneeling at your earlier grave to me
it's a neat reference to what Blood
Bones New Game+ represents it implies
that the dream continues even after you
pass through somehow the dream must be
useful to whatever maintains it be it
gurmann the moon presence or maybe even
the doll from what we've seen and did
you know that before you start your
final fight with German that it's
possible to PvP in the hunters dream
it's a pretty fantastic setting although
this isn't easy to do your sinister
resonant Bell is grayed out so the only
way to be VP is to summon help for you
in your boss fight and then kill them
the adversary system is one of those
really hidden mechanics in blood-borne
it relates to the fourth rune you have
memorized so it basically makes it so
that vilebloods can find executioner's
vice versa and also so that hunters of
hunters can kill blood
Hunter's for example if you're a
vileblood with the corruption ruin
equipped and you back in an executioner
with the radiance rune equipped he won't
be friendly he'll be your adversary
these enemies appear purple in your
world a mixture of the red of an invader
and the blue of a friendly if you're
trying to do this with a friend or a
group I recommend setting a password oh
and also if you have the hunter's rune
memorized according to the guidebook
there is a 5% chance that you'll be
matched with an enemy when you use your
small resonant Bell speaking of the
hunters rune its design actually has a
lock behind it
firstly it's almost definitely a
reference to the brand of sacrifice from
the berserk manga upon which a lot of
souls themes are based the famous
example is artorias there's also the
wheel skeletons featured in the manga
you should totally read it by the way
chapter 340 was just released so you've
got a lot of catching up to do but it's
worth it anyway the shape of the mark
always interested me - it looks like a
human hanging upside down and I think
that's what it just might be the
hunter's mark description describes it
as a dangling upside down rune which is
what clued me into it and there are such
people hung like this in the chalice
dungeons with their legs and hands bound
together in the symbol of the room I
also remember learning about this being
a method of torture where all the blood
runs to your head and you can lose
consciousness or die if you cut their
throat I imagine it's a good method of
draining someone for blood as well this
makes the next point even more salient
did you know that the hunter's mark also
spells the word Blood
reddit user Grey Cross first noticed
this about six months ago and it checks
out in most games you'd probably chalk
this up to a coincidence but it's crazy
how much detail from can put in
sometimes a tiny detail I noticed a
while ago was to do with pebbles they
look suspiciously like eyeballs don't
they I was looking at one after i looted
it from a crow and I was thinking hang
on
why are crows dropping pebbles and then
it clicked carrion crows eat eyes crows
drop pebbles pebbles look like eyes my
god to make this point a bit more
interesting did you know that there's a
crow in heme work
whose entirely non-hostile his placement
is in the middle of all these other
crows that you'll likely aggro when you
tried to kill them so it's just as
likely that you killed the friendly crow
when you weren't paying attention this
poor innocent crow it's all about the
little things
speaking of which always read book
titles in souls games there's usually an
easter egg or two in Gorman's Workshop
there's a book titled how to pick up
fair maidens not much use to you here
gomen another hidden thing is illusory
walls and you'd be forgiven if you
didn't even think these existed in
blood-borne turns out they're only
located in chalice dungeons none have
been found in the main game though we
should look out for some in the DLC
shouldn't we there are four in the lower
two marrow chalice dungeon one for each
floor but they're also known to appear
randomly in route chalice dungeons as
well number ten is to do with the silver
beasts in the nightmare of mensis did
you know that they spawned three maggots
upon death you probably didn't know that
I didn't I went through this area with a
fire buffed weapon and it turns out that
if you kill them with fire or a visceral
attack that the maggots burn up inside
and they won't spawn upon death it's a
pretty useful tip if you're having some
trouble number eleven is regarding the
forbidden forest gatekeeper Willem kept
two loyal servants back at Bergen worth
when they were sent into the labyrinth
they encountered the eldritch truth and
went mad one became the password
gatekeeper while doris became a grave
guard of the forest even in madness
though they remained loyal keep talking
to him and eventually he'll say this
that hazard
[Laughter]
it's as if he's feverishly reminding
himself even in his madness that that
door has to remain closed else people
will discover the eldritch truth hidden
at Bergan worth number 12 we've talked
before about how law can be lost and
found in translation and blood-borne is
no exception apparently according to a
post on the extra life wiki the original
Japanese name of the bloodletting beast
is host of the beasts blood which is
truly interesting I feel like we missed
out on a fairly important point of the
law here it could imply that the blood
of this creature started it all and it
also makes you wonder is there such a
thing as beast blood that's different
from the blood other people are infected
with the people of Bergen Worth for
example near ROM they've all turned into
insect-like creatures and the ones near
a brightest are alien like so how many
strains of the old blood are there
number 13
did you know that Miyazaki has confirmed
the skull in the grand Cathedral to be
Lawrence in the official strategy guide
he says that Lawrence's skull served as
the start of the healing Church itself
but it's taken the form of a twisted
Beast
it's interesting that he says that the
skull itself served as the start of the
healing church and not Lawrence maybe
Lawrence became the headless
bloodletting Beast we did just mention
that he was the host of the Beast blood
after all 14 has to do with the witch of
heme wick one of the best fights that
you can use low insight to your
advantage she spawns these mad ones
endlessly the first time you fight her
because you'll always have at least one
insight from initiating the fight but if
you want an easy fight just go in there
with no insight at all and no mad ones
will spawn it makes it a complete
cakewalk and lastly the hunter's dream
music changes if you acquire more than
40 insight it changes from this
[Music]
to this
thank you all for watching I hope you
don't mind I felt like doing a slightly
easier to make video after the last one
which was a much more ambitious project
I'd really appreciate if you checked it
out by the way it's about the artists of
the souls community and it's one of my
videos I'm more proud of I'm never
really happy with a lot of the videos I
put out but I'm pretty happy with that
one cheers guys I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
[Music]